habituellement il ya des milliards de
galaxies peut-on encore croire que l'on
est les seuls dans l'univers
en tout cas les seules doté d'une
intelligence gabriel chardin ce que la
probabilité ne s'est pas inversé en
faveur de l'existence d'extraterrestres
sur cette question là je pense qu'on
peut être beaucoup plus optimiste et
dans le sens à les deux galaxies en
galaxie c'est quand même ce serait très
difficile puisqu'on parle en millions
d'années lumière mais à l'intérieur de
notre galaxie environ un peu plus de 200
milliards d'étoilés très probablement et
là je dirais que on recherchera bien
dans les prochaines années des
indications d'existence de la vie à
travers diverses signature sur laquelle
on pourra revenir mais il semblerait je
pense extrêmement normal ou ou probables
même aux scientifiques et puisse exister
un grand nombre de deux systèmes
planétaires qui puisse abriter la vie
sous une forme ou sous une autre
[Musique]